no filter i don't no filter none at all
well you two are two peas in a pod you
know what jacks jackie's maybe i could
do yeah i'm looking for me bridesmaids
in my life so are you so he he popped
the question no he didn't if you're
watching
yeah i'm listening no your boyfriend not
yet let's call him right now yeah no
no
let's call him i don't have my phone on
me yeah i have i should know his number
do you want me to type it yeah i hear
you get the number oh god
oh god oh god just type it in uh i'm
shaking for him right now what's his
name his name is brave all right
ironically he hasn't been yet so come on
how long have you been going out uh
over four years now oh no it's time no
it is time and you're 25.
you want children yeah i do
body clock is ticking okay give her the
number
okay here we go oh gosh i hope he
answers i i hope so too it's always
better when you call somebody in the
answer and he's panicking he's on set
right now is he on set what's he
shooting i think he's actually doing
something i don't know if i'm supposed
to say this with mariah carey like so
that would be really funny i worked with
nick cannon
oh wow that's amazing it's her time
right now it's christmas time this is
your time
all right here we go comes out once a
year here we go here i know oh no okay
what did i do no it's good
plug it in oh plug it in plug it in
the dongle
quick
oh hi it's howie howie mandel it's howie
mandel
all right can you hear me
yes okay good so we can hear you i'm
sitting here with jax how we meet right
awesome and you're brave nice to meet
you okay so we wanted to do this in my
podcast we're live on my podcast now
i love that lou is here the voice of
fellow hello lucky dog and uh maurice is
here who you worked with uh last week
was that
a couple months ago on the post-modern
jukebox pinky in the brain
yeah that was one of my favorite shoots
and we just wanted to say
congratulations because uh jax announced
the engagement and we just wanted to say
you're a guy
and uh you can't breathe i guess
are you so nervous we're talking to you
about this because the lady with hair
won't let us talk about auditions
i'm i'm the voice of fluffy so what made
you what made you take that next step
why what was it how did you know she was
the one for you
oh it was the second i laid eyes upon
her
that's beautiful use these write this
down because you'll make a song okay
you're right you're right i gotta write
it
so uh it's been four years buddy
i know i know and i'm sitting here with
my daughter who is married with two
children and i'm thinking
why aren't you pulling the trigger is it
a ginger thing
[Laughter]
timing
what is the timing what is you what is
it you're looking for
what makes the stars a line
when she's least expecting it
she wasn't expecting it on this podcast
that's true
no do not make him propose on your
podcast why she doesn't want that she's
expecting no get down on one knee
that won't happen i i i i need to uh i
need to talk to her dad first you know
okay i'll get him on the other line give
me your dad's phone number
you're going to hear her dad in one
second we're going to put her down
oh my god
oh my god
here there we go
here we go entertainment this is so
exciting god i'm sorry
you might be ruining my plans right now
no i'm not no no i'm not it's just i'm
enhancing
there's a thin line between enhancing
and ruining we don't have another that's
okay we don't have another dongle
we don't have another dongle and
remember that's what she said
that is what she said
there he comes what's his name john
you're covering this oh
here's john hello hey john
john i was hoping you wouldn't answer hi
john
hi it's howie mandel
oh my goodness
hey big fan and you know what my wife
and i have big fans when you when you
were doing that little peeps kit too oh
that shows you our age okay well you're
a beautiful couple and you're a lucky
guy you have a beautiful wife and we
were just uh jax is on my uh podcast
right now and we just showed the video
of you her singing the song about what
she wants in a relationship
speaking of which guess who i have on
the other line
um
my wife no no no no no
brave
brave is on the other line okay brave
go hey brave what's up brave mariah yeah
you know just answering uh no caller ids
and uh
regretting it again
oh wait he can't hear hear that what you
can't hear me oh
yeah
oh put this up he goes answering no
caller id he says he's answering what do
i do oh my god this is hilarious you're
putting out you're not like me howie
no i know it's just the technology lou
is going to help me out okay can you
hear him now i'm going to help you with
the technology i usually go here don't
talk
the two brave john go ahead oh god john
go
hey brave
john can you hear me
uh
hello
hello
this is god right now
no uh brave wants to ask you something
translating no
howie
you're ruining it i'm not ruining it
don't do it i won't do it uh john i'm
gonna call you back
okay
no everything's okay it's a hundred
percent
you talk to your and talk to your dad
dad
how he's trying to
get your blessing on his podcast right
now
did you hear that she's saying i was
trying to get your blessing because
brave woman now he wants to marry me
pretty much that's exactly it
it's not really up to us apparently it's
all up to a woman with great hair
that's it ali ali gets to make the final
call who who i get married to
brave are you having a good time on my
podcast brian's panicking right now
she's
famous
i'm sensing uh sarcasm
he's panicking caroline said we messed
up we should have merged the calls we
should put oh how do we do that i'll do
that i'll phone you right back i'm going
to merge the call oh my god you want me
to wait here in the car yeah wait wait
and then we'll set it up we're going to
merge the call ready
she's going to do it on there she's good
oh okay and then i'll plug in that phone
i'm a guru hold on okay
i could do it hang on one second
i'm a merging expert plug that in i got
it okay great hello hey okay here give
me that phone are we are we merged
oh god
there's a pit in my stomach you you're
the one that merged it hello everybody
hello there we are
john and brave are together once again
are we yes
yeah okay i'm taking a step back go
ahead guys
guys
don't listen
you made this as awkward as it could
possibly get
brave
don't do it baby i'm very excited to see
you for thanksgiving this week oh
all right that's it
excited also you and i are gonna spend
some quality time together it's going to
be great oh there he'll ask in
thanksgiving oh that's a good time that
sounds great looking forward
brave is more traditional than i thought
somebody that jax would be with would be
he's the perfect combination i know i'm
kind of yeah these days
um i remember when uh uh alex who is my
son-in-law called me to ask for my
daughter's hand in marriage
i wasn't comfortable because i i don't
know if you know about me i don't shake
hands i don't want anybody to touch my
kid's hands
so
i said you could take the whole
the rest of my daughter just don't touch
her hands
you can ask her
you could ask for her conversation in
marriage yes yeah okay because of you i
got pregnant
what what because you wouldn't touch my
hands
now it's just getting uncomfortable now
it got weird welcome to my daughter
thank you for out weirding whatever that
was
my daughter's face i just found out now
i didn't know my daughter's pregnant
she's not married this is i don't know
if you know this daughter oh
thank you mazel tov is what you're
saying she's 13.
oh not not muslim no
but apparently she's friendly and people
like her she's very popular
she's not 13. she's not 13. she's been
married for 10 she's 37
i've been married
yeah i've been married for 42 years i'm
a lot older than your parents how old
are you john
55. yeah i got more than a decade on you
really yes yeah can you tell by my
hairline
i hope i look half as good as you when
i'm 65. me too me too because i tell you
being as gorgeous as i am is so
wonderful no i
the the tough thing let me give you some
of the drawbacks if i walk by a mirror
i'm usually late to where i'm going
because i got to stop and just
just kiss it yes
but anyway brave you are a gentleman
you're a lucky guy you're both two very
lucky guys you really are you guys very
professionally skirted around that that
skirted around that and i appreciate you
both for it and so
don't ask anything or do anything until
a song can be written that's all i'm
saying amen i agree with that i second
that all right and uh the lady with hair
i think i'm pissing her off i gotta go
all right oh god i'll let you both go
happy thanksgiving mr mandel thank you
thank you thank you thank you great god
bye john
oh i hate you
i hate you
that's that's everyone's sentiments
[Music]